was there ever any discussions about you
going over to ovo at all or
uh yeah we had it was it was discussions
it was it was discussions it was like
a thing for for a minute something you
were seriously considering
yeah yeah yeah i was considering it
really i feel like it
it could have happened you know i'm
saying it was just like uh
you know when i just used when i used to
talk to drake about it he was just like
he he released the pressure he was like
man i love you know saying
love to have you over here he was just
like i just want you to uh
you know a lot of stuff and they start
opening up to you
you know what i'm saying and uh
you know basically just telling me he
already know like
all the labels from to be coming at me
and stuff like that and to just
kind of like just wait you know me i was
fresh out there like i'm gonna decide oh
you know it's worse yeah you're gonna
get the crazy advanced crazy bag
type jump but i was able to uh
just do what was right for my career for
real like that
so so did drake like make an official
offer no
no no they never did i i never really
after he said that i never really like
pressed on it for real
all right you know what i'm saying i
never really pressed on it
so it was like just a conversation or
like quick conversation
uh his team was just like uh you know
what i'm saying when you
you know let us know uh
before you sign uh your deal just like
kind of communicate with us and just
let us know so we can you know have a
chance to talk things over with you and
stuff
it was kind of like just helpful like
just steering me
steering me up through the whole process
right
right without really just trying to make
me sign to them kind of give you some
big homie advice
yeah for sure yeah him and his team or
morgan i think morgan over there